all right so the mid 90s slasher scene
was completely gutted inside out and
upside down by the release of one
specific movie that scream baby Wes
Craven ghost face of twist on the usual
slasher genre all of this was a unique
mixture that captivated audiences and
somehow was able to get meta on an
entirely different level and is what has
kept this franchise alive for almost
three decades now but why did scream
become the horror slasher darling it is
today well it's because it bullied those
formulaic horror tropes from years prior
chewed him up and spit them right in our
faces while establishing a world where
these horror and slasher films live and
the characters are privy to the ins and
outs of everything that they watch a
whole new way to scream so join me pick
up the cordless and let me know
kicking things off since scream is like
a reinvention meta slasher the
characters have actually watched a
horror movie or time or two type movie
there are plenty of horror references
nods even blatant call outs Halloween
The Exorcist from Candyman the howling
Palm night psycho okay so I'll try to
touch on all of them as they pop up but
the main framework for a lot of scream
comes from 1978's John Carpenter's
Halloween specifically a mask villain
High School victims alone surviving
scream queen and the slasher rules to
live by which we'll talk about later
we're first introduced to Drew
Barrymore's Casey she picks up the phone
and the TV behind her has the blue dead
screen that used to show between
inserting VHS tapes into a VCR now
director Wes Craven added that this
little detail was to symbolize quote
we're about to see a movie Casey
continues talking to this stranger
saying her favorite scary movie is
Halloween ding ding first horror movie
drop but she also pulls a knife out of
the Butcher's Block while saying this as
a nod to the big old knife Michael Myers
uses in the first Halloween movie The
Opening scenario is a nod to one of Wes
Craven's favorite horror movies 1979's
When a Stranger Calls the whole Opening
12 minutes section is an intentional
homage to this movie while also weaving
in The Meta nature of scream Casey now
asks the stranger's favorite scary movie
with them responding A Nightmare on Elm
Street again continuing The Meta nature
because Craven wrote and directed this
Freddy Krueger classic Casey continues
by saying nightmare on Elm Street
scary wow well the first one was with
the rest soft now Wes Craven originally
wanted to remove this line saying quote
because I thought that would make me
look like an ego Maniac but Kevin
Williamson who wrote the screenplay I
mean screenplay
urged him that this is what real life
horror movie fans would say about these
movies so it stayed Casey goes on to
threaten that her big boyfriend football
player Steve will kick this stranger's
ass if he doesn't stop but right before
Casey brings up her jock boy toy you can
actually see a silhouette of him in a
chair outside on the porch which is
revealed in just a little bit but the
killer makes Casey play a game of a
horror movie trivia with the first
question being name the killer in
Halloween and while Casey is thinking of
the answer you can softly hear notes
from the Halloween theme song blended
into the background
very faint but it's there I'll do a
whole wrap up at the end of this video
covering which Ghost Face claims what
victims and surprise there's two killers
I'm assuming if you clicked on this
video you know it's Billy and Stu at the
end but yeah during the opening with
Casey and Steve both Stu and Billy are
here terrorizing them so when they ask
Casey which door they are hiding behind
it's essentially a trick question
because one is at each door that's why
the first runs in to the front door
unlocking it so the other can help stop
Casey Casey grabbing the big old chef's
knife is reminiscent of Jamie Lee Curtis
using a similar one in Halloween ghost
face attacks Casey through the window
slamming him in the head with the
cordless and then escaping now this was
director Wes craving actually in the
ghost face costume and she really hit
him in the old Noggin I forgot how
absolutely brutal some of these kills
were and Casey's is amongst the most
gruesome especially with her mother
hearing her last moments over the phone
but the sequence of Ghostface chasing
her is supposed to be based on
Leatherface chasing his victim is in
Texas Chainsaw Massacre also a bit
ironic that Randy calls Billy a
Leatherface later on in the movie
knowing that yes he is one of the two
ghostfaces there's a couple back to back
Halloween references as Casey is
crawling towards her parents but unable
to scream feels similar to Jamie Lee
Curtis crawling across Pavement in
Halloween 2 and then Casey's dad
mentions going to the mackenzies for
help which is ripped almost directly
word for word from Halloween get the car
drive down to the McKenzies
I want to go down the street to
McKenzie's house I want you to tell them
to call the police
Casey's death has a couple of other
horror references built into it one
being her hanging death being similar to
the iconic hanging in 1977 Suspiria but
also having a big name star like Drew
Barrymore you know obviously in the
promotions the posters everywhere and
then die off in the first 12 minutes is
not only a franchise reoccurring moment
that they keep using but also taking a
page out of Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho
where spoilers spoilers here I'm warning
you Janet leaves Marion crane is
unalived early on in the movie as well a
little behind the scenes look of these
opening sequences but apparently and
this I can't believe this is real a prop
Master had forgotten to unplug the phone
Barrymore was using causing her to
actually dial 9-1-1 a handful of times
wildly screaming and then hanging up
obviously confused operators called back
asking why they kept calling screaming
and hanging up with police being alerted
of the strange behavior I'm surprised
Ghostface didn't slice and dice the prop
man right then and there another thing
was that the MPAA essentially picked
apart this movie scene by scene saying
that it was far too violent and one of
the sequences in question was the
stabbing of Casey in the opening far too
graphic for them it needed to be
refilmed but Wes Craven just casually
said that this was their only take
entirely a lie so they caved and just
let him use it a hell of a start to
scream as we now settle into our main
characters introducing Sydney Prescott
and Billy Loomis Loomis being another
name that references back to Dr Loomis
Michael Meyer psychiatrist in Halloween
and also Sam Loomis the name of the
boyfriend in Psycho so Kevin Williamson
was cooking when writing this screenplay
the way Billy climbs through Sydney's
window at the start of the scene is
similar to that of Johnny Depp crawling
through the window in a Nightmare on Elm
Street completely intentional and we
learn he is maybe a bit off of his
rocker seeing he was watching The
Exorcist at home another horror name
drop hope you're paying attention
because there's a quiz later as an
acoustic cover of Don't Fear the Reaper
begins to play as Billy sorta confesses
his lust for Sydney and in a way this is
a reference and foreshadowing with the
song tying back to Halloween when Lori
and Annie are cruising around getting
stoned but also a little wink wink to
the audience that Billy is someone to be
feared because well he's he's a ghost
face boy throughout this scene though
Billy takes Sly looks at Sydney's door
obviously because he doesn't want her
father to walk in because this could
happen at any moment right yeah but a
bit of a theory time here I think it's
because Stu is also at the house and
this is when and how Neil Prescott is
kidnapped Billy distracted Sydney Stu
snuck in and a classic ghost-faced grope
and grab maneuver it makes sense to me
but uh let me know in the comments and
if you're enjoying our breakdowns of
older movies stab that like And
subscribe Button as it helps all of us
out here at heavy spoilers right back to
it uh High School baby the best and
worst time in everyone's lives as we see
authorities and news crews taking these
deaths of Casey and Kevin very seriously
The Surreal synth choir like butt rock
music and I say that with all due
respect I don't even know what kind of
genre of music this is was something
that felt out of place to me but also
very much setting the tone for the
seriousness of these teen slames Sydney
is called to answer some questions from
the police force and you sort of get a
feeling something weird happened in her
past specifically her mother but we only
get hints of this right now behind
Sheriff Burke some of the names listed
on this set decoration are actually cast
and crew that worked on the film
specifically the art department now
Burke is played by Joseph whip he also
just so happened to play a police
officer in a Nightmare on Elm Street
this was purposely done with
screenwriter Williamson stating so the
backstory there that I put in is that he
was so upset by the events in Nightmare
on Elm Street that he moved to a small
town in northern California so like it's
it's all connected man we're finally
introduced to the whole Mystery Inc gang
talking about everything that's
happening and in the scene we get a bit
of their relationships personalities
High School clicks that they maybe
belong to but the main takeaway from
this scene is all of the sly hints at
Who The Killers may be and again after a
couple re-watches I just couldn't
believe how obvious some of this was
first is Stu explaining to Sydney how to
gut some someone with Billy basically
leaning in and telling him to cut it out
hey it's called tax you [__] rag then it
said that Stew was dumped by Casey for
Kevin so there's potential motive there
Billy and Stu are wearing similar black
boots which we later see Ghost Face
wearing and ties back to the shaking in
my boots line on the phone with Casey in
the opening both Stu and Billy have the
easiest same Alibis both going to their
girlfriends Sydney and Tatum's the night
before so that takes the heat off of
them and lastly the few looks Billy
gives to when he basically is just
giving himself up to them right then and
there right after Stu says I didn't kill
anybody nobody said you did
thanks buddy besides and finally Billy's
concerned look after Sydney leaves and
Stu makes the liver jokes again very
subtle but all of these looks and tone
in the banter seems very sus at this
point in the movie Sydney cautiously
checks her mailbox going back to Randy
hearing a rumor that Casey's body parts
were found in her mailbox since scream
was like the first in an evolution of
slasher movies very much taking a
satirical approach to certain slasher
aspects the music cue when Sydney opens
the closet
[Music]
thank you
is completely there to mess with the
audience's expectations there should be
a jump scare when she closes the door
but in reality there's nothing we
learned that Sydney's mother was
brutally assaulted and killed only a
year prior and potentially these new
slains could have some sort of
connection as Sydney wakes from her nap
receiving a call from Ghostface quick
behind the scenes Ghostface was voiced
by Roger L Jackson and during filming
none of the cast actually met him he'd
be hidden on set somewhere and this was
purposely done so the cast's reactions
to his voice were much more genuine and
at first his voice was entirely a
stand-in a placeholder for later dubbing
but Craven liked the intelligent but
evil tone in his voice and it just stuck
back to the ironic satire of scream as
Sydney beat for beat explains the tropes
of generic horror movies but then
follows them almost identically not
going out the front door instead running
up the stairs but not before Ghostface
jumps out of the closet and attacks her
now the earlier floor Creek actually
maybe probably hinted someone else was
already in the house
foreign
is when Ghost Face slams Sydney's head
into the floor and [__] his head
slightly similar to Michael Myers right
after he stabs a victim to the wall
which I'm pretty sure is featured on the
TV set at Stu's party later on Sydney
freaking out over Billy having a cell
phone also those black boots again is
entirely warranted because both Billy
and Stu were there to terrorize her
Billy was the one who called her
taunting her while Stu was the one in
the ghost face outfit this is also
picked up on re-watches because each
Ghostface has a different stab style and
other things like wiping the blood off
of the knife but don't worry we'll we'll
touch on that later
teeth
probably the most unrealistic thing is
that the police show up to Sydney's like
in 45 seconds flat response time is
incredible Billy goes to jail and Sydney
barely escapes with her life Tatum
finally arrives to pick up Sydney
driving an old style VW red beetle now
this is a reference to Stephen King's
The Shining in the novel Jack Torrance
drove this style of vehicle which was
later referenced in Kubrick's adaptation
being wrecked by a semi if you want more
of The Shining we did a full breakdown
on that so check it out right up there
but uh net now now back to scream this
line from Kenny the cameraman was an
intentional ad-lib Jesus the camera
hurry my name isn't Jesus perfectly
adding to the subtle humor scream
encompasses now this is where red
herrings start to throw viewers off of
the scent of who actually is Ghostface
by making it seem like Sydney's father
May potentially be the killer because
Dewey can't find him registered at the
Hilton he skippedown the night Casey and
Kevin bit the dust it's been exactly a
year since his wife passed away and that
the costume Ghost Face wears is called a
father death should have been daddy
death because hey alliteration the ghost
face mask itself has a bit of an
interesting backstory originally
developed by Fun World The Mask was
partially based on the cover of the Pink
Floyd album The Wall mixed with the
ghostly looking characters that appeared
in 1930s that he Bop cartoon the mask
was randomly found by a producer that
was scouting locations for the movie
they liked the ghost in pain screaming
look and asked if they could license it
for stream changing the name of the mask
from the peanut eyed ghost to the iconic
ghost face mask which is still owned by
Fun World today so now that the mask was
picked they wanted Ghostface to look
like a legitimate ghost straight up
Scooby-Doo style and originally had a
white robe to go with the mask but uh I
don't have to tell you this there was a
bit of a visual problem with the design
it looked like a KKK member so they axed
the white robe and replaced it with
black saying that it would help the
villain blend into the dark better and
honestly save them a lot of PR questions
at Tatum's Sydney gets a call which
turns out to be Ghostface now thinking
about potential suspects at this time
with Billy being in jail it can't
possibly be him because at the police
station there was a sign that mentioned
calls will be screened so he wouldn't
risk giving himself up but like that
meaning that there must be someone else
or he's working with someone spoilers we
know this but you know here's some more
evidence for you crime solvers out there
Nick Cave and the Bad Seeds red right
hand song plays during this transition
which is a huge on the nose take of
what's happening the killer has a red
hand red because of blood but when will
you break down the song it's alluding to
Divine Vengeance which means the ghost
face boys think that they are doing this
working for higher power their killings
mean something grander once Sydney and
Tatum are back at school this random
reporter tries to jump them for answers
and this is an uncredited Cameo by Linda
Blair another hidden horror movie icon
if you know you know but if not she
played Reagan in the original The
Exorcist this was a delivered homage to
the [__] classic according to Craven
via the DVD commentary another
deliberate horror homage is the number
10 Jersey Tatum is wearing it seems
awfully similar to the kind of shirt
Johnny Depp's Glenn wore in the original
A Nightmare on Elm Street after the
Little Ghost Face prank in the hallway
Henry Winkler's principal scolds the two
students who put on the prank but also
is a clue to the final reveal that there
are actually two different ghostfaces
even the blue flannel with t-shirt look
the one on the left is wearing is oddly
similar to the outfit Billy is wearing
at Stu's party later on but the
conversation is another huge red herring
because principal Hembree has motive
after his little Spiel fairness would be
to rip your insides out hang you from a
tree so we can expose you for the
heartless desensitized little [__] that
you are I touched on the ghost face mask
a bit essentially its Origins but it
almost didn't even make the cut because
Bob Weinstein one of the heads of
Dimension films thought that Ghostface
was quote idiotic the look was just not
even scary that was until he watched the
opening scenes with Drew Barrymore and
completely changed his tone saying what
the [__] do I know about dailies and ask
Craven to move faster to get the movie
out even sooner a city-wide curfew is
put into place for the killer you know
still being on the loose so that drives
Stu to throw a big old party at his
place now when inviting Sydney and Tatum
though Stu sort of pumps his fist in
more of a stabbing motion than your
typical excited fist pump which is
another strike against Stu maybe being
the villain of this all Henry Winkler
now has his time to shine and scream
even though he was asked to go
uncredited for this role the rationale
from producers was that they didn't want
to distract the attention from the
younger lesser-known actors at this time
also his death was added after the fact
because again old Bob Weinstein stepped
in again complaining that roughly for 30
pages of the script no one had died and
you know what someone must die this
allowed for Winkler scenes here and also
an excuse for the kids to leave Stu's
party later on in the film now there's a
couple of small cameos as well with
Henry Winkler's The Fonz leather jacket
from Happy Days hanging in his closet
and the janitor he talks to is named
Fred and dressed identical to Freddy
Krueger from A Nightmare on Elm Street
only missing is you know his iconic
knife glove this is director Wes Craven
in the outfit who also directed That 80s
horror gem principal hembrey's death
with Ghost Face reflected in his eye
resembles the same iconic scene from
Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho Tatum gets far
too meta combining horror directors Wes
Craven and John Carpenter as a fun
little nod to the influences scream uses
you're starting to sound like some West
Carpenter flavors this brings us over to
the video rental scenes with Randy as
there are several horror movies shown or
tossed out by Randy first of course is
the oldest of horror movies Frankenstein
playing on the television to open up the
scene and then Randy name drops 1981's
the howling along with the 1980s prom
night in Randy's ramblings he also goes
to paint a picture of how this is all
going to end and will play out
mentioning Sydney's father will show up
somewhere in the final reel he's a red
herring in all of this and that Billy is
the real killer even goes on to say it's
the millennium
Motors are incidental which is kind of
true here like there really isn't a
clear motive as to why they're killing
people again with Scream taking on this
meta within meta approach to the
franchise this forward-thinking Easter
egg of Sydney saying Tori Spelling would
play her if there was ever a movie made
about her comes true actually in Scream
2 because spelling ends up being the
lead in the stab franchise so just
genius casting or some intern was paying
hella attention to things the
conversation with Sheriff Burke is all a
smoke screen to who the killer may be
focusing on Neil Prescott is obviously
the way Williamson intended with the
script but Burke is also wearing black
boots the same as Ghostface this is all
intended to be a misdirect according to
Wes Craven even with the ominous musical
cue when Burke Stomps out the cigarette
we're finally to the giant house party
murder Fest end all of scream and it
never dawned on me until re-watching but
the ending is like 42-ish minutes of
them at Stu's house which is a massive
chunk of the film's 111 minute run time
and brings all of our main characters
into one central location again throwing
you off of the scent of who the actual
Ghost Face may or may not be the fun
begins with Tatum heading to the garage
to grab some beers if you know your
music this is a bit of a hint at Tatum's
fate as Drop Dead Gorgeous by Republica
plays right before she opens the door to
the garage which must be uh yeah yeah
that you know what okay that's that's a
cold garage but to be honest this was
always one of my favorite moments in
Scream because it's the first and only
mention of Ghostface when naming the
killer yeah the only time in the whole
movie that they call him ghost face no
please don't kill me Mr Ghostface I want
to be in the sequel but also the comedy
of having beers thrown at him and
clumsily falling almost like a cartoon
the clumsiness was something director
Wes Craven actually was concerned about
cutting a sequence where Tatum hits him
over the head with a painting like
straight up a Looney Tune style the
stunt with Tatum trying to escape via
the doggy door was the complete disaster
when trying to film due to Rose
McGowan's petite frame she kept easily
sliding out of the door when filming it
just didn't look right like she was
stuck in the door so in order to fix
this they nailed her clothing to the
frame of this appearing to fill it out
much more and the rest is history as one
of the most creative and brutal kills in
the scream franchise Billy and Sydney
head up for some privacy and we can see
that he's wearing that similar blue
flannel like I mentioned in the
principal's office earlier he also
casually drops a Silence of the Lamb's
reference which is a bit ironic for how
the events of this movie are a sociopath
manipulating his female counterpart and
being showcased in the scene urging her
into doing the deed this brings us to
the horror rules that scream lives by
and makes meta commentary on he may not
survive the movie if you have sex if you
drink or do drugs and if you say I'll be
back hello and who's there these rules
are the framework of all the horror and
slasher movies that came before
specifically Halloween in this example I
love how Scream blatantly gives you this
formula but the horror rules are also
played into later movies like Cabin in
the Woods evolving the horror genre
rather than the stereotypical cookie
cutter approach pausing Halloween on the
knife coming down behind Randy is a
great image but also four Shadows later
when Ghostface pulls up behind Randy on
the couch the phone call about principal
Hembree causes almost all of the party
to bail and check out his hanging body
but if you listen closely to the
students leaving one yells hi ho silver
foreign
this is a nod to Stephen King's It where
Bill one of the protagonists has a
silver bike and refers to it as such
here the student is driving a silver car
this sets up Dewey and Gail to find Neil
Prescott's abandoned vehicle in the
Woods by Stu's place this obviously
raises the Spidey senses however his car
was hidden in the woods a couple of
nights ago the night Casey and Steven
were murdered and Stu kidnapped Sydney's
father when Billy was distracting her in
the opening where he climbed through her
window or at least that's what I think
anyway Billy is attacked by Ghostface
causing Sydney to run now there are a
couple of details in this small chase
scene that gives a bit of a hint of who
is behind the current ghost face one is
that Sydney is instantly cut off through
another door meaning that this person is
very knowledgeable of the layout of this
house hint hint still and notice some of
the mutilated dolls in the Attic when
Sydney runs through whoever did this is
clearly demented and even the hanging
one can be tied back to Casey being hung
in the opening and this is Stu's house
so it's pretty telling stuff but I never
understood how Randy didn't hear all of
the commotion upstairs maybe he was too
drunk but this is a meta on an entirely
different level because sure Randy is
watching Halloween telling Jamie Lee
Curtis to watch behind her because
Michael Myers is behind her much like
Ghostface being behind him on the couch
but Randy is played by Jamie Kennedy so
it's almost like him telling himself to
look behind him that the Killer is there
but of course he doesn't take his own
advice the final Chase amongst Sydney
and Ghostface is is brilliant because it
weaves all of the characters still alive
where they are in relation to the house
and the game's Ghostface is willing to
play like Sydney hiding in the police
Jeep only for Ghostface to toy with her
with having the keys and and then
slightly opening the back hatch is
perfect because we see it we as audience
see it and know what's happening while
Sydney is absolutely out of the blue no
clue what's happening which leads us to
the final unhinged reveal that both
Billy surprise and Stu are the ghost
face Killers throughout this movie
though their motives are a bit thin
tying back to what Randy said at the
video rental store it's really Billy and
Stu's inability to distinguish reality
from movies this is why they mirrored a
lot of their kills off of other media
and quote or even name drop specific
horror movies like Billy mentioning
psycho and Carrie in this final sequence
they even go as far as mentioning a
sequel and returning for it which now
makes me think like what if scream
absolutely like tanked at the box office
what a swing and Miss like Dracula
Untold in the Dark Universe Cinematic
Universe anyway billions do specifically
stew are dialed up to a 11 for this
finale really goofy fun stuff but with
the constant changing of who is on top
The Killers or Sydney this drives her to
Dawn the ghost face outfit and stab
Billy with an umbrella a couple of times
now A behind the scenes look at this
sequence but the stunt man actually
misses the padding on Skeet ulrich's
chest on the second thrust and this was
a genuine painful response from him
because Ulrich had some wiring beneath
the skin for open heart surgery as a
child so the pressure on his chest
caused serious and real pain in this
scene the final kill on Stu with the
television is another great staple to
the scream series and again following
the double tap Trope of horror villains
in the final meta moment like every
villain isn't actually done they come
back for one final scare and Billy
unaliving for that final scare and then
Sydney getting the final bit of
Vengeance for everything she went
through in the movie now if you have
some patience there's one final Easter
egg tucked away in the credits and it
has pettiness written all over it so
with roughly 45 seconds left this thank
you section Scrolls up followed by no
thanks whatsoever to the Santa Rosa city
school district governing board this is
because production had been given verbal
permission to film The High School
scenes at the Santa Rosa High School in
Northern California but after word got
out about the violence of the film
thousands of people showed up to public
hearings protesting the filming because
what they were told or sold on was that
this is going to be a comedy saying it's
actually a bad look for the school and
City obviously this was a huge stab to
the gut for the production of the film
luckily though they moved things to the
Sonoma Community Center in the city of
Sonoma for the high school scenes but
Wes Craven couldn't help but add the
petty ending in the Ed credits aside
from that event scream had some crazy
uphill battles in the behind the scenes
Department before it became the
glorified horror slasher that changed
the horror genre forever and is beloved
by loads of movie fans so I mentioned
some edits because of the npaa well
originally scream was rated NC-17 and
did not secure the R rating that they
wanted that is until Wes Craven told
them to view everything at the point of
view of a comedy rather than a horror
film this instantly changed things and
they got their R rating but also scream
was released in theaters I I can't
believe they did this five days before
Christmas the furthest thing from a
family-friendly holiday movie but they
did this because of obviously counter
programming there were absolutely no
other horror films in sight but scream
only did 6.4 million in opening weekend
causing it to instantly be labeled a box
office flop how however the buzz of Word
of Mouth eventually blew this thing up
making well over a hundred million in
the U.S box office a handful of sequels
and even had a ripple effect causing
caller ID usage to increase three-fold
compared to before the movie was
released scream was a cultural change
for the tired out horror and slasher
genre it completely flipped the script
allowing for a meta nature to the tropes
and characters at play and allowed for a
handful of other horror films or maybe
even copycats if you call it that
depending on your point of view to
thrive in the coming years like I Know
What You Did Last Summer and the
underrated 1998 urban legend solid flick
the idea of scream and Ghostface even
jumped to the parody genre with a bevy
of scary movie movies being made to poke
fun at Ghostface and the Gang which is
honestly meta in itself because scream's
original title was scary movie and
wasn't changed until like late and I
mean late in post-production on the film
oh and I almost forgot but what victims
belong to what ghost face is is as
follow Stu claimed Casey Stephen and
Kenny while Billy claimed principal
Hembree and Tatum most of the time they
were both there helping one another like
moving Casey and Steve's bodies but the
initial killings are what I just listed
with both having a role in Marine
Prescott's murder but yeah everyone has
fond memories of watching scream for the
first time or even at a scary movie
sleepover and we've all seen the iconic
ghost face every single pretty much
every single Halloween since the mid 90s
but yeah let us know in the comments
what's your favorite scream memories are
and if this still holds up after almost
three decades of shaking up the genre
and I'll let you know we're currently
running a competition giving away three
copies of the rocky 4K box set on the
15th of March and all you got to do to
get a chance of winning this is like
this video subscribe with notifications
on and drop your memories or thoughts or
anything on screen we picked the
comments at random at the end of every
single month and the winners of last
month on screen right now so if that's
you message us on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch be sure to check out some of our
other cool videos Scream 6 we have an
ending explained for that and then also
plenty of other breakdowns but with all
of that out of the way thank you for
your constant support I've been Jared
I'm not gonna lie I'm very sick and I'm
glad I could get through this all I'll
see you in the next one take care and
peace